stephen hawking geht mit einem knall ab
als am 14 märz starb hinterließ er
vielleicht seine bahnbrechende arbeit es
wäre ein geniestreich eine theorie von
paralleluniversum wir könnten sie hier
in unserem universum bestätigen
gemeinsam mit dem belgischen physiker
thomas hartung soll er eine multiversum
theorie entwickelt und jetzt wurde sie
veröffentlicht und ist damit peer
reviewed worden also wissenschaftlich
nicht zu beanstanden
jetzt also alles über die letzte arbeit
von stephen hawking krieg zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen
während der arbeiten an dieser theorie
hatte der belgische physiker thomas
herzog schon das gefühl dass es
vielleicht die letzte arbeit von stephen
hawking sein könnte die kommunikation
wurde immer schwieriger aber er hat das
gefühl dass hawking noch nicht sterben
wollte jedenfalls nicht vor der
fertigstellung dieser arbeit dieses
gebiet und seine arbeit daran sei das
gebiet auf das er am meisten stolz
gewesen sein
hawking und er überprüfen in der arbeit
mit modernen mathematischen methoden die
inflation des universums nach dem
urknall also die schlagartige ausdehnung
in den bisherigen theorien gibt es eine
unendliche inflation des universums
zitat die übliche theorie der ewigen
inflation sagt voraus dass unser
universum global wie ein unendliches
fraktal ist mit einem mosaik aus
verschiedenen taschen universum getrennt
durch einen aufblenden ozean so hawking
in einem interview im letzten jahr
herzog und hawking sagen jetzt aber
voraus dass es anders ist demnach gibt
es diese taschen von angenommenen
bewohnbaren universum so gar nicht die
annahme dass es unterschiedliche
universum gebe manche leer manche voller
materie manche die nur kurz existieren
und nur in unserem universum wäre
zufällig leben möglich diese annahme sei
nach ihrer arbeit falsch mit der
stringtheorie widerlegen sie jetzt die
theorie der ewigen inflation nach ihrer
theorie ist vieles viel einfacher
demnach gibt es diese verschiedenen
universen gar nicht sondern sie sind
alle ähnlich zu unserem universum herzog
dazu das rätsel warum leben gerade wir
in einem speziellen universum wo alles
schön ausbalanciert ist für die
komplexität und die möglichkeit leben zu
entwickeln
das konnten hawking und er nicht glauben
sie rechneten alles durch und kam zu der
bahnbrechenden theorie der multi wersen
die und jetzt kommt es überprüft werden
kann wenn ihre theorie stimmt dann
müssen die gravitationswellen die vom
ende der anfänglichen schnellen
inflation unseres universums ausgegangen
sind darauf hinweisen es wäre ein
rauchender colt der untersucht werden
können allerdings haben die
gravitationswellen sehr lange
wellenlängen die mit den aktuellen
niveau gravitations sektoren nicht
gemessen wird
können aber die europäische
weltraumagentur esa plant einen viel
größeren gravitationswellen detektor und
zwar viel viel größer im weltraum er
soll zwischen erde und sonne gebaut
werden und zwar an dem punkt an dem sich
die gravitation der beiden gestirne
aufgibt der erste test satellit wurde
bereits erfolgreich ausgesetzt das laser
interferometer space antenna system kurz
lisa wird aus drei satelliten bestehen
die jeweils achtung 2,5 millionen
kilometer voneinander entfernt sind beim
nike und dem aktuellen
gravitationswellen detektor liegt die
länge der aber bei vier kilometern
es werden bei einem gravitationswellen
detektor ja die interferenzen zwischen
zwei im 90 grad winkel zueinander
verlaufenden laserstrahlen gemessen
werden sie durch eine gravitationswellen
durchlaufen ändert sich jeweils die
raumzeit der beiden strahlen
unterschiedlich werden sie dann
miteinander abgeglichen bilden sie
interferenzen bei einer entfernung von
2,5 millionen kilometern ist dieser
gravitationswellen elektro viel
empfindlicher
da sich die verformung der raumzeit auf
solange entfernung fiel deutlicher aus
wirkt der start des systems ist für 2034
vorgesehen dann erfahren wer vielleicht
schon bald wie ob und in welchem
multiversum wir leben wenn er als erstes
neues nationen zu allen anderen themen
erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer bei whatsapp oder bei teno
gramm oder nimmt mit mir über instagram
oder facebook messenger kontakt auf
dafür hier klicken dann erfahrt ihr von
mir vor allen anderen vom 19
täglich garantiert ihr könnt doch direkt
über mich in der redaktion von kriegs-
und mitmachen und mitbestimmen was hier
wirklich passiert kriegt also hier drauf
in der begrüßungs nachricht ist übrigens
ein kleines goodie versteckt und
natürlich nicht das abo mit der genau
glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter
mit dafür auch draufklicken hawking sagt
weltuntergang voraus ansonsten bis dann
bleibt kann